hello and welcome to video playing Scout
chess Scott I mean I know if this is
referring to to this but Scott is a
German German a card game no German I'm
not sure if it of three of German origin
but it is very popular in Germany this
is the way to properly describe it why
is that working
hmm it really shouldn't it really should
that isn't the one shot game
what is the difference that's his famous
game buddy one should be in black but
this is different this is different
it is different somehow I don't think I
screwed up the move order
9595 this is this is but this is not the
same thing why is that working I don't
get it I go back and then what what is
the point
yeah I'm just I'm just a piece up here
it just doesn't work but I feel to
remember the difference we have to work
this out after the game there is a
famous line where this d5 was is
equalizing but I wonder what what is
what is whatever
what is the difference their money is
just a piece
you can check me actually
check on c5 yeah what's possible
as such I cannot remember this is really
the weirdest thing I usually have a
pretty decent memory for for opening
lines but I don't remember how that
exactly went the one shot was black
a little bit strange yeah what I'm doing
right before t7 Oh a little bit while
trying to remember that game I miss
played this a little bit
still oqg one
[Music]
25 or what no no I think I've got I've
got some control back back of this
position what's a little bit weird yeah
but it's just check him bishop all night
night I guess 26 I can just take g7 the
rooks are quite strong here it just has
one check right so I can go look g8 and
win the window bishop
I don't remember that the tricking game
so this is the right start of it and
default chick
you know I have to cancel this is the
thing castles and then I've got to be
three yeah or no no it's working and now
it's working this is the thing now it's
working here here and then you've got to
see six exactly this is the one show
game
okay now I got it right so you have to
delay castle and this is actually and so
I did it right this is what I remembered
it somehow that you that you first
complete this and only then Castle it I
was completely irritated yeah somehow
it's too too much sometimes that you
have to keep in mind
yeah and nobody five doesn't work just
doesn't work yeah in this other
situation here
d5 okay let's look at this night eggs
there's immediately six this is not
great
there's something like that yes this
threat and it is hanging and yes he
takes not at all and the most critical
one is this this this e six and then
black is fine this is a funny move as a
reply but after like playing on this
trick but after takes takes takes and
then I think whatever 95 or so it's
completely equal yeah white has to avoid
Rudy castle so I did it right there
should be three here b3 and now this
doesn't work he confused lines naughty
I'm just a piece off really yeah but I
played while trying to remember those
subtleties are played to play this a
little bit to in a bit of a too relaxed
fashion and I might it there might maybe
there was something that he could have
done before g550 too
we should bear to okay it seems to be
fine but I was a little bit concerned
that I might overlooked something which
it's not the case so I was always some
just a piece up and no problem at all
yeah sometimes you confuse move on us in
particular this is a common issue you
know the ideas and everything but then
in okay wasn't display of it anyway
thanks for watching